Jennifer Lopez calls out her husband Ben
Affleck for being so serious just try
not to look stupid out there you know
what I mean I'm just like well it's not
too big don't smile too small Ben opens
up about being guarded with the press in
a new Interview With The Hollywood
Reporter admitting that he worries if he
says one thing wrong his career might be
over in my life
um
been through a lot of different kinds of
experiences with the press and it's just
a it's like a function of what you do
right it's not my favorite part of the
job it's not what I would choose to do
but it is a responsibility it might take
seriously and you have to promote this
work now Ben is sharing the advice his
wife gave him to relax be himself and
have fun it's gonna be a special moment
in my life and in our journey together
Ben says Jen reminded him ahead of his
thr interview that he's a fun guy who is
real and genuine but sometimes he just
seems so serious Ben agrees with his
other half explaining she's right and
she loves me she's looking out for me
she's trying to help me so it's like
maybe I ought to listen to her and
speaking of looking serious yeah I gotta
go I gotta go all right I got no no Mom
no Mom it wasn't the actual devil yeah
remember that Viral moment from the 2023
Grammys where the cameras caught
Jennifer Lopez giving her hubby A little
nudge to perk up well after a lot of
speculation Ben reveals what Jen really
said in that moment when Grammy's host
Trevor Noah put them on the spot it
wasn't the actual devil I leaned into
her and I was like as soon as they start
rolling I'm going to slide away from you
and leave you sitting next to Trevor she
goes you better not leave so there you
have it mystery salt what can I tell you
we're just having a good time and while
Ben may have looked super stoic at the
Grammys he says he had a good time but
admitted it was definitely his wife's
work event that's a husband and wife
thing I mean some of it is I'm like all
right who is this at like I don't keep
up my wife does obviously it's a funny
thing life and art the way they kind of
intersect at the time A source told ET
that JLo and Ben knew they were going
viral in real time but brushed it off
which which was echoed by a seat filler
who was at their table JLo actually
handed her phone to Ben and said hey
honey look at this meme that's
circulating about you so they were so
well aware during the Grammys about it
another source told E.T that the
newlyweds actually had a great time but
Ben looked low energy because he was
feeling tired Jen knows Ben is a great
husband and they still made sure to have
a good night together
[Music]
thank you